he's been taking pictures for 40 years
akan bodo akan bees life has straddled
many cultures he was born in Oxford grew
up in Nigeria and now he lives in Berlin
he originally came to the city because
he wanted to write photography means
writing with light so I still right I
also write with words but also with
images so my thing very much as a
narrative I want to tell stories and
especially tell stories about so-called
mega cities really big cities but I
don't tell stories in this kind of
linear sequence it's very much more jazz
it's much more trying to fragment eight
the way we are more let's live today
lagos nigeria the place of his childhood
it's africa's fastest growing city with
an estimated 20 million inhabitants I
can be exposed order in what appears to
be the chaos of every day urban life
there an attempt to sweep away the
cliches about what some people call the
lost continent aqueon whether the
curator has brought up the term are for
pessimism I don't believe some questions
what there is a tendency to show Africa
Nigeria Lagos in negative terms and many
I wasn't trying to work against this
a mediator between different cultures
Cambodia can be is trying to change the
way people see city life in Africa now
the continents most important
photographer has been named a winner of
the 2016 Goethe medal